or now there I'm gonna find I'm gonna
get you get you get you get you one way
or another I'm gonna find you I'll get
you I get you I don't know the lyrics
take it overhead again don't wait I'm
gonna find ya I'm gonna get you
alright welcome to dream boy - why is my
face not there
why does Liam look like he's on LSD
every picture Liam what the [ __ ]
new game pls this game is sexist
oh [ __ ] I scared again I'm sorry
wow I am offended this kind of looks
like my tears so let's go with that one
I guess alright Mets yeah she's 21
secret I know
oh my it has all the charm she has very
little strength but she has all the
knowledge that much knowledge oh I love
this game already it's amazing oh my god
my mouth my mouth my mouth does this
little glitter thing is this the game
cuz I'm pretty amazed by it holy [ __ ] Oh
huh Jess who is destined for me oh my
god I can't wait to find out uh which
path will you take I don't [ __ ] know
will your dreams come true well I'm
playing dream boy - is I [ __ ] doubt
it will you find your true love
[ __ ] yeah Harry stage oh my god Harry
will it be Liam Payne page with every
eye will it be Nile [ __ ] Nell Horan or
will it be that one guy that no one
knows really who he is but he keeps
showing up at the end of the song or
will it be who is that
she's cheating on my husband now wait
the opposite find your destiny or am
bored ok meltia today is my first day at
school
I am excited yet a bit nervous
I just moved here and I barely know
anyone wow what a loser I hope I get to
making you some friends today I doubt it
I doubt it
let's go to the 1d headquarters you're
late for class oh [ __ ] alright go to
school the school bell rings today is
there where is one direction I don't
have time for this [ __ ]
there they are welcome Harry Louis and
Niall oh my gosh no one cares manana
they're my classmates hi everyone
the three of us will be studying here
for this semester this is probably my
favorite game out of all time I just
love it so much
alright well I want to talk to [ __ ]
Oh God not him
yes Harry here we go let's get that
flirt on who the hell it
[Music]
um hug and kiss him get away from me
goddamnit I didn't work or you serious I
hurry get away from me okay hi Harry
oh hey that worked but the [ __ ] why are
they so [ __ ] rude
[ __ ] [ __ ] alright fine I'll talk
didn't Liam he better not Disney hi Neil
what's up hi um ask his name
no no thanks I'll [ __ ] you too hi
hi Liam a million exclamation marks why
can't I talk to them I don't have I
don't have enough energy to deal with
you right now Zayn Louise won't let me
in now I won't let me in Harry won't let
me a Liam won't let why won't no one let
me in I don't have enough energy alright
finally go home oh this game is hardcore
there we go now we have energy again
same still won't let me in in his house
alright can we do something work
I gained some money well I want anyone
talk to me
god I hate you all is this a game to
make me hate them cuz it's working god
this game hardest game I played some
pretty hardcore games Dark Souls rage
games everywhere but this game just
takes it all who the [ __ ] are you Perry
excuse me but I need Zayn right now what
the [ __ ] oh all right he's back hey babe
Zane is a [ __ ] babe what's happening
what's happening all good babe
so we start with you do the bad ones
from my direction and then we work our
way up to Harry Sal's got it hey babe I
don't feel comfortable being addressed
as a babe I maybe I may be a babe and I
may be a [ __ ] but I don't babe me all
right ask his name
not now babe this day all right let's
try now don't triple dot me [ __ ] I will
trip a lot to your ass if you know what
I'm why would they let me in in this
goddamn house and what happens when they
let me in their house what kind of weird
business what's happening all good babe
I said we're living in Italy leveling up
this [ __ ] I love you okay
ouch ouch that hurts
none happy I've never been so immersed
in the game in my entire life oh god I
don't have enough energy to talk to
these hoes Jesus Christ you burned out
energy by literally doing nothing in
this game
for [ __ ] sake Taylor you're a goddamn
[ __ ] blocker Taylor Taylor I'm talking
to Harry right now leave us alone you
[ __ ] cockroach I'll never forget this
Taylor hi Harry oh hey whoa look at my
XP damn that just skyrocket hug and kiss
him get away from me goddammit
and this game really has a lot of depth
like you go to sleep you wake up you
talk to one direction and then you go to
sleep the life of a fangirl
people don't realize how hard it is and
you repeat the same [ __ ] three
conversations over and over and over
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is this do I have to listen through this
I'll thank god oh god oh god no no
thanks no thanks Nile oh god I find it
it's right there Wow you find old words
relationship with old boys increased by
suck my dick 1d literally now wait no no
no no no no you got it all wrong why
won't they let me in there has I didn't
understand all right I want some money
take the [ __ ] gift yes Liam is now
fully you and Twitter congratulations
relationship [ __ ] yeah
that's ride you [ __ ] you haters
didn't think I could pull it off did you
this is the perfect fitting song for
this epic moment oh it's like when you
caught that one Pokemon Liam I love I
goddammit I broke I broke do you do you
like me I'm sure why not
okay you got a plea cool fine girls you
gotta play it cool just like I'm doing
right [ __ ] now uh-huh Liam oh hi can
we give him a gift now or some [ __ ]
that's brace phone number how is that
close friendship if you don't even give
me my number you [ __ ] I'm sane what's
up [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you marry me now
ask him to follow you on twitter god
damn it why is it so hard to make
[ __ ] follow me on twitter i think
we're ready to ask his name I'm Harry
though apparently if you just ask
someone their name and the answer your
your friends
I got damn it then he won't follow me on
Twitter though yeah yeah I know what
cares about you Louis oh you [ __ ] well
that was an
nothing they are fangirling whoa day 15
huh you have exam today you want
deciding no [ __ ] that I want a 1d take a
sample
no ah come on
so much fangirling effort just lost baby
which happening hey baby
now not really really lazy can be me
sure but where let's get to the karaoke
area I always get baby to bed ever it's
good to practice it myself I can't see
any way I'm gonna sing now anyway I'm
can you can you stop its you're making
me feel uncomfortable Zayn saying I was
saying say please put on your clothes
caught on your clothes oh my god did I
do it
sorry you were terrible you were amazeen
oh good danger gage name whatever just
keep your clothes on please wait it's
your turn now yeah no not me I don't
know how to sing
get me heating doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo okay
oh my god I actually get to sing holy
[ __ ] ah oh my god oh my god oh my god
and again and again and
the best ever maybe is your way she baby
situation walk straight I am hard so
let's do the dirt and pass the guards
just like she already owned it I said
can you give it back to me out of this
as you said never in your wildest dreams
I know
[Applause]
make it rain make it rain make it rain
on them hoes 94 94-94 you bichos [ __ ]
yeah oh what happened
wow you sounded great why thank you
saying you should be usually be a thingy
you should join expected we're singing
can't it wait really
no I'm just kidding you ruffle brunettes
you could also be like this anyway ftk
Nia I have to go back and practice in
that studio thank you for coming give me
your waking I mean yeah but you're
welcome
I really busy alright let's do this yeah
are we invited to the saints house why
for [ __ ] sake Zayn now for [ __ ] sake
you cake Blackie all my energies just
get drained from that [ __ ] like I've we
went through all that [ __ ] and you won't
even follow me on Twitter like what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh hey Liam you doing
anything today no nothing much really do
you want to go to the mall or something
sure let's go do you want to buy
anything help I'll buy them for you [ __ ]
yes he'll you have it here you can have
this I think you're Liam thank you oh
thank you anyway do you want to play
some more kids let's play air hockey
spend this much time in this game you
awful [ __ ] Liam Liam you're supposed to
let the [ __ ] live it Liam you're not
supposed to try hard
Liam confirmed trihard [ __ ] point for
me I'm let's write you you stop going in
my side Liam god I hate layup layup
that's right Liam [ __ ] dick face no
Liam now what is wrong with you Liam
Liam worried yes in your dick Liam blew
him I've got a [ __ ] murder you I
swear to god Liam
leave stop stop Liam hey hey I hate you
stop attacking the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is that
you're not [ __ ] you wow yeah wow you're
good at this game we should do this
again next time I have to go now I see a
band I guess okay take her this is my
favorite game they still won't let me in
their house and I don't know what's up
with that in your face [ __ ]
heavy stances follow me on twitter [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's right that's right uh-huh
ask his phone number who the hell are
you you really you literally pull that
car didn't you you just followed me on
Twitter you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Harry boy hi Harry
oh you're going somewhere no not yet can
you come with me okay I need to practice
my solo for concert can you play the
piano for me all right Harry play a
piano challenge oh my god quick okay
okay whoa what the [ __ ] am i doing what
is this I don't know man
alright that was gay you did pretty good
I can practice my solo for little things
right now I have to go now okay I'll see
you later around still while I'm in
their house though still won't let me in
their house you know what let's do a
save here and then we'll continue if you
brothers like this video I will very
much appreciate it
cuz I went through some name [ __ ] to get
here but anyway I hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did
here's the profits for you